- Yeah, the thought of getting clean
and actually having to feel this,
like this being upset is medicated,
being clean and not
having anything to like
numb these feelings
and they have to feel this,
I don't want to, honestly.
I don't want to know what
this feels like without drugs.
- [Mark] All right, Megan,
Megan where are you from?
- Cleveland, Ohio.
- [Mark] Cleveland.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- I did till I was about five
and then my parents got divorced.
My mom was on drugs.
She was a IV drug user cocaine,
I have seven brothers and sisters,
I dunno, it was kind of fucked up.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Good and bad.
When we were with my mom it was bad,
'cause she was on drugs.
Our lights were shut off,
we had lice, no phone,
my dad eventually got custody of us
and he was together, but
it was too late by then.
I mean, I was molested
by two of my brothers
and at that point it was too late,
I didn't want to go to school,
I didn't, it was just..
- [Mark] And this went on for a while?
- Went on for yeah, for a long time.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- It started when I was probably eight,
until I started my period
and then it stopped.
- [Mark] You got, you
went through high school?
- I dropped out my senior year,
I had son when I was 16.
- [Mark] Oh right,
and where did your life go after that?
- I got married actually,
I had a pretty good life.
Then my husband, I started doing pills.
My husband's dead, he overdosed,
we were on pills and then heroin
and then heroin and cocaine together
and now I do both every day.
- [Mark] Heroin and crack.
- Heroin and crack,
shoot coke, smoke coke, whatever.
I have seizures all the time
from it, from doing cocaine.
- [Mark] So you started when you were?
- I started doing heroin when I was 28.
- [Mark] 28.
And then how would you
support yourself after?
- I put an ad on Back Page
and was selling my ass on Back Page.
- [Mark] In Cleveland.
- In Cleveland
and then I met a guy that had money,
moved in with him and he moved to LA,
so I followed him to LA,
met a dope dealer in LA
and I'm a cute white girl,
and so he moved me into
his second apartment
and it was good, I had
all the dope I wanted
and then his wife found out about me
and so now I'm kind of
in between here and there
and on the streets.
- [Mark] And where's your child?
- I have two children.
I have a boy and a girl,
my son he's doing great,
he graduated high school, he's in college.
I have a 15 year old daughter
that's with my mother-in-law.
They're both doing well though.
- [Mark] And you stay in
contact with your kids?
- Little, 'cause I'm
ashamed of myself, I mean.
- [Mark] Shame's a big deal.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Mark] And you came to
LA, how many years ago?
- I've only been here
about a year and a half.
- [Mark] And what, you
came out here for your..
- My boyfriend.
- [Mark] Your boyfriend.
- And he's back in Cleveland now.
And I'm here 'cause I met a dope dealer
and I had endless drugs, so..
- [Mark] That keeps you here.
- Yeah, I just met him right now
and he gave me money, gave me dope.
- [Mark] And how do you
support yourself now?
- Men.
Men and I don't look like
an average dope user,
so people are nice to me.
Not yet I mean, it's,
you know, gonna happen,
I got bruises all over my body.
- [Mark] And where are you staying in a..?
- Right now I'm staying
at some guy's house,
I don't know, I don't even know who he is.
I don't know where it is or I just
the person that's driving
me knows how to get there.
- [Mark] And do you, I mean,
tell me where you're at with all this.
I mean, are you seeing
that you're destructing?
- I know I'm a mess.
I just had a seizure the other day,
almost fell and busted my head open,
luckily somebody was there and caught me.
I'm going to die out here.
I know, if I don't quit
doing what I'm doing,
yeah, I'm gonna die.
- [Mark] And I know better than
I know the answer to this question
but I'll ask it anyway.
Nothing can get you to stop,
I can't reason with you,
nothing, it's not about that.
- No my husband dead in a
casket couldn't get me to stop.
- [Mark] What do you
think the core of it is?
Is it just you believe you deserve?
- No, I know I don't like,
I know I'm better than this.
I know I'm smarter than this,
drugs are a motherfucker.
Thank you.
I don't know, it's
the first thing when I
opened my eyes in the morning
that's what I want, I
want to go get drugs.
- [Mark] What do you
think about others don't,
people that don't do drugs,
don't understand about it?
- I don't know, 'cause I didn't
understand until I did it.
I don't know.
Honestly it just, and now
I'm physically addicted too,
so the heroin, if I
don't get it, I get sick.
So it's not even a mental thing anymore,
if I didn't have it,
I couldn't be sitting here,
I'd be throwing up, I'd be hot cold.
So I don't know.
- [Mark] What's been the roughest,
the darkest point?
Right now?
- Yeah now's pretty dark.
There's rats running around
the streets out there,
it's disgusting.
Crazy people.
I almost wish I was crazy,
so I wouldn't know better.
I wouldn't realize how fucked up this was.
- So how you spend your days now?
What's your typical day?
- Chasing money.
Just whatever I have to do to get money,
this morning I've been out
for two and a half hours
and I've called my boyfriend in Cleveland
and conned him into money.
He thinks I'm in rehab right now,
so I bull shitted him and told
him I needed stuff in rehab
so he sent me money.
I called my dope dealer guy,
he thinks I'm in rehab too,
or he thought I was supposed to be,
so I just bullshit people
all day to get money and...
- [Mark] Because you need what you need.
- Yeah I need what I need
and want what I want.
and you become cold and
callous and you just...
- [Mark] You do whatever
it takes to get it.
- Yeah, you will.
Especially at the end of the night
when the drugs are gone and drugs are gone
you have nowhere to go and it's like fuck,
it's hard.
- [Mark] What do you think
would actually help you
turn the corner and climb out of this?
Anything?
- I don't know, I don't know the answer,
if I knew I would do it.
- [Mark] Yeah I mean,
people would say rehab
but then you have to want to do rehab.
- I don't have money to go to rehab.
I don't have insurance to go to rehab.
And so that rehab to go to,
I might as well be on the
street, 'cause they're dirty,
they're gross,
so be on the street least I'm high.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What's the most important lesson you feel
like you've learned?
- Don't do drugs,
that's it, drugs
and I should know better,
my mom was an IV drug user
I mean, I was five years old finding
hypodermic needles in the house.
I know better than this, but it's hard.
It's hard, it takes over your whole brain
and they're putting
fentanyl in everything.
Cocaine, I have fentanyl test
strips 'cause I get needles
at the exchange and they give you tests
so you can test your fentanyl
and it's in cocaine, it's
in meth, it's in everything.
So everybody's getting
physically addicted now, it's not
and once you have that
physical addiction, it's
I've ruined my body from it,
my teeth are a mess.
- [Mark] And the fentanyl
makes it tremendously,
very dangerous.
- Yeah, it'll kill,
it's killed my husband.
He overdosed 30, brilliant guy
he's a software engineer, dead.
And we always thought
it's not going to be us,
we can always get everything back.
We can get our house back,
we get our cars back.
We can get our jewelry back,
we can get all this shit back,
but once somebody is dead,
that's it, you can't get it back.
You can't get this time back.
- [Mark] You think there's
a better chance of you
ending up dead than getting clean?
- Probably, if I'm been
being honest, yeah.
Yeah, 'cause when I leave
here, I'm going to go use,
that could be it.
- [Mark] And you've been
living like this since,
for how many years now?
- I'm 36.
I've been, since my husband
died is when I've been like
kind of on the streets
and like living in hotels
and doing whatever, for five years.
- [Mark] Five years.
- Five years.
- [Mark] How do you see
that those five years
have changed you?
- I'm cold, I used to be caring and kind
and funny and smile and I'm cold,
I don't care about anybody,
if they're not getting me my next fix,
I don't give a fuck about them.
- [Mark] Do you think you're
you think it might be the fact
that your mom, your
role model was an addict
that led you here or do you think?
- No I don't so.
I don't think so,
I mean, I'm sure that didn't
help my psyche, you know?
But no,
no, I mean, she's fine now she's clean,
she's you know, she's made her amends,
she's no, I brought myself here.
- [Mark] How did your mom do it?
- She just did,
I don't know if she lost
everything and just did it,
I don't know, I don't know how she,
I don't know how anybody does it honestly.
It's consumed you.
My first thought in the morning is,
where am I going to get drugs?
My last thought before I go to sleep,
it's not even fun, I'm not
getting high, having a good time.
I'm not out dancing,
laughing with my friends,
it's not that, I sit by
myself and smoke dope
and shoot dope, it's not fun.
This isn't a good life,
these people out here,
we don't love this.
It's what it is, we're here,
California dream right?
- [Mark] Do you feel like your less
than perfect childhood might've set the..?
- I'm sure it didn't help.
I'm sure it didn't help.
My parents divorcing didn't help,
my mom, yeah no it didn't help.
But I mean, we all make
our own choices, you know?
I don't blame anybody for-
- [Mark] But the things
you went through kind of,
continued
- Yeah I mean sure my-
- [Mark] You don't deserve any better.
- Yeah I have times I
think like that, you know
I was molested by brothers.
I was raped in high school
by a brother's friend.
So sex means nothing,
so selling my ass means nothing,
'cause the sex means nothing.
When it's been taken from you
basically your whole life,
you might as well get
something for it right?
It sucks, 'cause I know
I'm better than this.
Like when I actually like sit
and really like use my logical brain,
I know I'm better than this.
Yet, here I am.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's almost
like there's two parts of you.
One part can logically say
that you're better than this
and the other part
subconsciously thinks you're not.
- It must.
- [Mark] Because you're intelligent
and you're sensible
and you know you deserve better,
but there's a part of you
that keeps pulling you down,
making this, okay, this is acceptable.
- It's my life, so it has to be,
I mean, if I just thought
how horrible it was,
what's that going to do?
- [Mark] Do you feel
like you were loved ever?
- By my dad yeah.
Yeah I had a good dad, he was a good guy.
It was just too late, he just...
- [Mark] He came into your life at what?
- No he's always been in my life
but my parents divorced
and my mom had custody of us
and we didn't, he didn't know
and when he found out it
was too late, you know,
we didn't want to go to school,
we didn't even want to
brush our fucking teeth.
I mean, we had no, you know
no sense of like normal, you know?
So, you know, he comes
and takes us from our mom
and wants us to go to school
and you know, live normally,
we don't want that, we were
like wild animals, you know?
- [Mark] So today do you have friends?
- Real, like friends?
- [Mark] Real friends.
- No, no.
- [Mark] No one you trust?
- No, I just, I actually just came across,
came into like $20,000,
spent in a week on drugs with one person,
that person I spent it
with, is not my friend.
It's a person that has a car.
- [Mark] And $20,000.
- Well the $20,000 into my arm
and their arm and their pipe, my pipe.
Yeah, one week.
- [Mark] What's the most degrading thing
you've done for money now?
- Some sexual thing, something sexual
I don't know specifically,
because there's been so much,
just last night I was down on Skid Row
in somebody's car and they're,
went down on me and somebody
comes up to the window
while they're doing it because
they thought I'm a hooker
and they want me to leave with them,
and that wasn't even for money,
that was just cause I'm
partying with them, so why not?
- [Mark] That's a crazy
life you're living.
Are you able to step out of
it and then look at yourself
and go, man, what have I done?
- Oh, I do and that makes it worse,
because then I have to
look at it and it's,
that's a big pill to swallow.
- [Mark] More shame.
- Yeah, the thought of getting clean
and actually having to feel this,
like this being upset is medicated,
being clean and not having anything
to like numb these feelings
and they have to feel this,
I don't want to, honestly,
I don't want to know what
this feels like without drugs,
because it's, I've done
a lot of bad stuff.
A lot of bad stuff.
- [Mark] Therapy might be the answer,
climbing out of this.
- I think I'm beyond therapy.
- [Mark] What's your biggest regret?
- Pick one.
I guess it would have to be
using in the first place,
'cause that's what
brought all of this here.
So if I never did that,
I would probably be okay.
- [Mark] You could have
picked a different family.
- I can't regret that, I
didn't have a choice in that.
- [Mark] I'm just joking.
- If I could have, yeah
hell yeah I would have.
I mean, my brothers were
molested by an uncle,
so I can't blame them for
doing it to me, they didn't,
it was done to them.
- [Mark] Somebody asked
my mom the same question,
what advice would you
give to someone else?
And she said "Pick your parents well"
- Yeah, really, I mean,
but they're people too,
you know, but yeah it's..
- [Mark] Forgiveness is the answer.
- Forgiving yourself is the hard part.
- [Mark] Yeah, forgiving yourself,
forgiving your parents,
forgiving everybody.
- That's the hard part.
- [Mark] And taking responsibility
for everything that's gone on.
- It's a big pill to swallow.
It's a big pill to swallow.
It's never enough.
There's never enough money.
There's never enough dope.
It's never enough.
Like I said, 20,000 in
a week and that's no,
I'm not exaggerating,
I'm that I'm not bullshitting,
like it was probably more
because I made money while,
I mean, I came into this chunk at 20
and then I made money and gone.
Like I have $0 in the bank right now.
Like I said, I had to hustle
this morning to get money.
And last week my bank
account had $20,000 in it
and it's not enough.
You just want to get higher
and
I don't know,
I don't think it's,
maybe I have a death wish,
maybe I don't know.
- [Mark] Have you ever been
suicidal or cut yourself?
- I wish I had the balls
to kill myself, I do,
I don't though, I don't have the balls.
If I did, I wouldn't be out here.
Death would be easy, this is hard.
Skid Row is hard.
Especially being a white woman
on Skid Row is really hard.
It's really hard.
And not being from here,
these people think this shit's normal,
rats in garbage cans and
running down the street,
God it's disgusting.
It's life though I mean.
- [Mark] All right Megan,
thank you for coming in
and talking with me.
- Absolutely, thank you.
- [Mark] And I hope you turn a corner
and figure something out.
- Me too.
- You're still young and healthy
and beautiful and intelligent.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You can.
- All of that and here I am.
- [Mark] Yeah, I know.
It's a common story though.
- I know, we're all out here.
- [Mark] Yeah.